Eve it's wonderful to see you  how does tell me how does Greg compare  to me as a leading man Oh Bob well  there's no comparison yeah you're right  why should we hurt him  it's my privilege to announce the winner  of the award for best achievement in  costume design the nominees are Theodora  van Runkle for Bonnie and Clyde John  Truscott for Camelot bill Thomas for the  happiest millionaire Irene sheriff and  Danilo Donati for Taming of the Shrew  and Jean Louie for Thoroughly Modern  Millie the envelope mr. moon the winner  is Jon Truscott for Camelot  I really didn't expect this at all so I  don't quite know what to say so may just  say a simple thank you